oh that feeling when you realize there's
only like 10 minutes left in the episode
I know don't revive me don't
end what a glorious day reject Nation it
is time for Loki season dose could not
be more excited I rewatched season 1
over the past couple weeks I think it
climbed to the top actually I was like
you know what I think this beats One
Division for me COI my friend he
literally just shot a very long podcast
interview with uh Yuri lenthal who plays
Spider-Man map and there the voice we
got to start working on the edit for
that it's a great great interview it's
going to launch on this channel
hopefully within the next week and a
half or so keep a lookout for that and
John he he helps set up the audio hell
yeah for John thanks guys all right guys
well you know what to do leave a like
leave a glorious like on this video also
subscribe and click the notification
Bell because you know we're going to be
covering all of Loki and yes full length
retion watch long re single with your
own copy available for super sex Rejects
at our patreon page but because this is
the first episode of season 2 it is
available for the public for free just
Link in the description box lastly
massive massive thank you to all who
have been supporting the channel by
getting yourself some reject apparel at
reation shop.com wearing this citizen
king shirt one of the first shirts we
ever created we just launched this shirt
snip snip from Ahsoka we got this child
protection services shirt we got this
space baby shirt we got this shirt we
got that shirt we got that shirt we got
a whole bunch and September was actually
our most successful month ever so thank
you guys for helping us have a grand a
month ladies and gentlemen you know what
to do reaction is going to start now
that's how we go all right let's do it
oh I'm so
excited man the wait is
[Music]
over oh my
goodness
Pazuzu
oh man I got I'm so jacked
right what is going on Mobius it's me I
don't know
you yes you do come
on who
Who attack of the
clo who whoa he's like that going to the
to TVA this
time
K oh don't you harm Casey great shot
wow Cal
your those meditation minutes
in waiting for the screen to
fall I'm fine I'm fine morning here
people are going to die from that truck
yeah is the driver
fine
well should be
fine there we
go the organization is cracked Casey
help me please tell me you know what's
going on don't you remember me there's
some Deja Vu to it I got him I got the
intruder oh damn
it
whoa oh interesting displaces him in a
different time or setting I think it' be
a different time in the same setting
something terrible is happening I'm
being pulled
from it is the same room same time I was
in the
past oh where's Mobius they probably in
Chrono Bay
3 so
no
L not used to being so handheld in by
shooting the TVA handheld in these kind
of longish
takes I haven't felt this level of like
excited anticipation for Marvel in a
minute even as the guy who's cool with
phase 4 we tell the people of the TVA
the truth about this place and you think
people are going to be ready to hear
that got to hear the truth man they
should have the chance to live those
lives think about it everything you've
been doing is wrong and all your God
you're
dead ok's here he disappeared right in
front of me he looked like he was in
pain maybe Miss minutes can locate him
do not rely on Mis minutes hey I have a
question yeah jet skes seos one of these
calling your name obus maybe gently
Whispering oh it's calling baby everyone
thinks that it's a personal watercraft
and it's actually a brand same way
Kleenex is
oh I don't think he really cares I don't
care I care General Doc and judge gamble
would like to see you both in the War
Room wonder what that's
about I'm so glad ra Al is part of the
Marvel
Universe what a menacing Dreadful
start jeez man well this like a 70s
horror shot right here yeah where is
he a war room he's just pushing through
Man Poor Casey this has just been the
weirdest
[Music]
day so we're answering to the judges
Council now there is like a weird 70s
horror way to shooting this WOW obvious
I was just doing my job it's actually RN
Slayer really owes me the apology
well God those effects are disturbing
yeah this whole thing is
eerie
[Music]
jeez man oh awesome
cut oh it's her from The Witcher you put
out an order to stop pruning into the
microphone Hunter we are doing this by
the book and on the record and she's
from Game of Thrones make it make
sense make it make sense this should
have been the next appearance of Kang
this is like exactly what I want so
Sinister
yeah I like
ants you are quite a Marvel Marvel huh
you made a difference in this war thank
you for being on my
team spooky for us for all for all time
always is Rona yeah I will be proud to
lead with you oh that must be what Miss
minutes gave her oh right at the end of
uh last episode Sky hasn't fallen what
sky are you looking at are you seeing
this robot head on the table changes
everything this changes
nothing I'm sorry Hunter if we don't
protect it my man we haven't been
protecting we've been destroying mhm
yeah we have to take a moment to
understand we don't happening a moment
you've made your position clear we don't
have time for protocol now succumbing to
the political Dogma was a good
debate such great craftsmanship to
the Symmetry and editing Justin AAR
killing this we can't go back to pruning
those branches I can do anything she's a
rogue
variant you didn't confirm someone's
going to say it tell the TVA to stop
pruning effective
immediately waa hello there
M you know me hey Al whenever he enters
a room it gets handheld just a moment AG
down tell me you recognize me you know
me a moment ago you didn't know me stand
down destroy the wall
Loki
oh
that's who built this place that's who
stole your lives that's who's coming
back oh I just got chills everywhere
come on should hit me for a
time prun you next
time but the warnings were real seems
pretty straightforward to me what we
need to know what happened at the end of
time find some soie she's a EAS and we
in this m holy corruption is deeper
than we expected I just want to time to
think slow down Loki you want it time to
think so let's think it's okay this
looks like it's shot on film it's
beautiful more of him that coming that
old coming you to kill the devil we need
ants that's the only way to stop him we
fought Mobius and she kicked me through
a Time door well and ask who won but it
was a draw you both kicked each other
through time it's not about that guys I
wish i' had more time don't do the good
what shirt just focus on what we know we
got to get a handle on this glitching
thing man that is what we know War whoa
damn see that all the ks KS he keeps us
safe I you believe that he built this
place no no how would I not remember
that CU he wiped your
memories I was in the past what do you
mean in the past where in the past here
here the past TVA no there is no past
TVA wow it's impossible it's possible
B timey Wy oh did you see it yeah I saw
it what is it how does it how does it
look how does it look I mean how does it
feel a CR counter it's it's all that
that really I mean it
look they call this minutes no what you
can't trust her she was there a with him
God their chemistry is so good yeah I'll
swing You by repairs and advancement
come on no no doctors where's that I
need to be back in there come on M I
know you're trying to help me whoa great
reflection pan we need to address the
fact that you keep disappearing I I keep
disappearing we don't have
[Music]
time you just disappeared I know and I
can't keep looking at it cuz it's
horrible I was
lying think you're being born or dying
or both at the same time really it's
freaking me out how does it look oh God
jeez time you're into the past that's
when I started all this all I know is I
was in the past 17 minute lunch break
wait that's who you said had my memory
wiped yes he remains is that what you're
calling him or that's his name pretty
arrogant it's like calling yourself last
man standing dude this is shot
incredible it does not feel committee
made and it matches the aesthetic of the
TVA really well I have no memory of
having my memory
wiped
that I love that
lot it's been a while since I've been
down here I mean going all handheld
really captures a disillusionment of it
all the energy is so high whereas like
season one where you're in the fantasy
my
man good we're in the right place the
ultimate guy in the chair I want to
introduce you to I'm or Boris Ora Boris
Boris that's awesome I call him OB
that's like a nickname I have wow how
long has it
[Music]
been 400 years what you got off on the
wrong floor and I told you it was the
wrong floor wait that's right
[Music]
yes he left immediately
god well I'm back it's great trip down
memory lane he was my last visitor wow
reunited and it feels so good hey how
are the other guys doing what other guys
what other
guys the W is really pile up if I take a
break so I just keep add it forever
forever sleep for all time always it's
got that strange 70s sci-fi horror
there's that Terry Gillum touched to it
the set's beautiful so how's the team
doing up there you know about the Tim
Keepers
in oh yeah that time slipping wait time
you know that yeah you've seen that yeah
you need fix that no impossible to time
slip in the TVA I know but we just saw
it happen yeah I'm having trouble
reconciling
that I'm having trouble reconciling that
he is the perfect person to add to this
world Boris um is he back 400 years do I
know you it's your future my present
it's complicated I've been pulled
through different times this match frame
circles is so time slipping in the TVA
it's impossible to time slip in the TVA
but you just saw it happen yeah I'm
having trouble recing that I know look
like your friend was time slipping but
it must have mean something else because
I've never seen anything close to that
happen before but you've seen it in the
past upload the memory he just got the
memory it's filling in now how did I not
remember that wait is he talking to you
in the past and you're just now
remembering it wow that makes perfect
sense oh this is so strange I love it I
guess time we is possible at the TV so
you remember what did you tell them a
linear time in this impossible yes yes
great editing in the future I think I
would remember that yes but it it's the
future it sure would be more convenient
if we were having this conversation in
the future and this were the past this
is
the never
mind someone in the time you want to end
up in would need a temporal Ora
extractor do you have one of those I do
not well you've had 400 years to build
one h D
it Jesus can you hold on to that until
my friend mobus drops by no
wait
yes I actually do have an extractor
here I love it so much Temple or
extractor is right there you need to get
to the temple Loom so the extractor can
pull Loki directly out of the time
stream but if you spent too long in it
that kind of Temple energy will peel the
skin right off you
not too bad compared to what Loki has to
do violently rip myself from every
thread of time and space all at once all
at once so the hope is that after you
prune yourself the extractor will pull
you into the
present but what's the present his
origin point but how do we decide what
the present is if it doesn't do that
have you heard about how if you fall
into black hole you turn into spaghetti
no good the less you know about that the
better yep is that what Wanda did at Mr
Fantastic yes everything everywhere all
at once
damn it hey no's back what you'd rather
be automically disassembled and never
reassemble again then have your skin
ripped off that at least you get to live
it's a quality of life with no
[Music]
skin
oh it's Morse code we're having power
surges all through the
TVA what did you say uh-oh he's not
having fun anymore it's it's code is
moris code yeah timeline is branching
now how bet that's what's causing the
power surges and maybe you're time
slipping really how wow these sets
temporal Loom that's bad you know the
temple Loom it's in the TVA guy book it
was one on every desk at the
TVA it's a detail index of every
mechanical good catch I can't get over
how cinematic this
is I wrote it myself this is wide frames
the most beautiful sets I've seen in a
long time
I this has actual movie
Magic not just like CG they're walking
in a
place like there's just lubing
dread and the details and the signs the
posters the floor what what I think is
great is that the TVA has always had
this 70s production design especially
with equipment and stuff and this time
they're actually choosing to hone in on
the visual language of those kind of
films yeah matches the the Aesthetics
who cereb bro I I haven't seen 2001 of
Space Odyssey but that makes me think of
what everyone's told me about 2001 of
Space
Odyssey hav't seen Temple Loom is the
hot of the TVA it's where raw time is
refined into physical timeline what raw
time it's not constructed to weave
together so many new branches so it's
overloading how horrifying danger looms
beyond the temporal Loom it looks like a
disaster it is a
disaster
that feeling when you realize there's
only like 10 minutes left in the episode
I know don't revive me don't end I need
to close the blast doors to protect the
TVA once those doors closed we won't be
able to resyn you so it's now or
never dear God ticking clock now but now
isn't for a little bit we still got to
get mobus into position but
[Music]
first h from the time stream before I
need to close the blast doors
Loki green means prune if you're too
late you will be lost to time forever
and Mobius will lose all of his
skin you got about an
hour you've got about 5 minutes oh Jesus
Oh No when I use this thing I might to
make
it looks like the thing a little bit
especially with that warped classic
warped face design
[Music]
mhm I love that they're using the
falling imagery but it's falling through
time instead of physical space like he
does the the throwback but it's falling
through time Hair
Whip future not
past way the future there's also a bit
of that Christopher Nolan touch on how
he would capture a Sci-Fi Story the
sound design too is really Nolan nah
dude I can hear too much of the that's
dialog agent away your suit so get down
the gameway lock the temple AA extractor
into place and hoof it back to the
moment I tell you to you suit will age
away you will age away and you'll get
very old and all your skin will get ped
away just keep bringing it back to
that is this
cracked
oh ready to see some hoing like you've
never seen
before okay
mean seen it all you
know love how like wow be movie sci-fi
Tech it all feels yeah he's like so
outdated dive to the bottom of the sea
or
something
waa waves of time
wow what a horrifying scenario
beautiful
oh that's my first chills moment that is
so cool threads of time forming a
rope
time great race against the clock
here
[Music]
wof get your suit peeled
off come
on oh still
[Music]
time just look how tangible and intense
everything is this is episode one
they're doing so much yikes oh boy oh
boy
no
whoa no green time
try
sck it's Trinity answer it we need to
close the blast do now give him more
time he can still make
it come
on this does feel like Matrix right yeah
it's like about to press the
EMP yeah in a
hallway move faster Loki yeah come on
dog you know you're on a Race Against
Time right
now is that is you I'm gonna get
Silvie oh Jesus
three three oh not yet give him more
time
sorry no no no no no no no no no no no
no what's happening there's nothing you
can do for him he's lost to
time love how it looks like musculature
under the first layer of the
[Music]
suit was an alarming ass
POV yes come out oh no there you are
[Music]
yes oh no
dang
God that stretch Zoom
D
wow
who yes beautiful oh that was awesome we
need to find
Sylvie yes we do actually the printing
usually happens so so fast but that
looked excruciating what he was going
through
yeah where are they
going everywhere all this for Sylvie I
don't buy
it no
no yeah Justin a sheepers man
brilliant wo that was brilliant oh
there's new credit
stuff
[Music]
oh
he is that an old
banana black holes I'm picking up
nothing TVA
soup Isaac Bowman did great
work wow
we now music I thought the writing was
good on this one too
I didn't recognize the writer's name but
this suit too has to be a tribute to
some sci-fi classic sci-fi movie feel
like the design looks familiar the
cosmic stuff was straight like Starin
mixed with Kirby but I I didn't
recognize the suit it must be a movie
thing or maybe I just don't know that
cos there was a photo of them touching
heads from
earlier whoa this looks like they took a
page out of the American Horror Story
credits uhoh even the credits are so
ominous uh uh
uh give me one of
those I love are those kings fighting
always there the show does that they
could have yeah I think we would have
noticed it but I honestly they could
have not shown
us
yes wait is this where Rono is but not
82 was
it oh she's going to
McDonald's McDonald wack
ARS how do I do this what would you like
not squirrel not possum not rats and
nothing with a face
please you could have a life could be me
and
me I want to try
everything oh my God she's going to be
fat as hell in 20 years very quickly she
won't make it in 2023 damn that was that
was brilliant guys that was was that the
best episode one that I I mean it's
theion it's the first season two we've
ever had of any Marvel property and uh
yeah episode one that was insanely great
um yeah they because the last episode of
season one ended on on on a on a great
ominous horror horrific Vibe and the
there were so many theories of what what
was happening when they saw the king
satue and they didn't remember them like
did they rewrite time the king rewrite
time is he an alternate timeline and the
explanation that they ultimately gave us
like oh it's genius and they work it
into the physical Stakes at what's at
hand what they got to solve like it's
not just something that they explain way
and then they resolve it because I I saw
like this one very little tiny nitpick
and and it was something but then there
was a one bigger criticism that I was
actually having that I thought might
have undone some of the Goodwill of
season 1 for me when I was seeing the
trailers was like oh man you know uh I
like I love the ending of season 1 it
was so so menacing and then you're like
but it kind of undoes that whole like
character Arc and the journey that Loki
and Mobius went through in that season
if you don't remember each other yeah
but then they solve and then they solve
it have but it doesn't feel like course
correction like no that feels like
that's maybe what the plan was the whole
time maybe it was maybe it wasn't it
fits perfectly cuz this got a new writer
remember that wasn't the original
showrunner writer is not on season 2 so
wal no no no the um the woman who
directed the director Kate Harry yeah
yeah sorry there's no show runners in
Marvel uh the the Kate Heron is not on
this so I don't know cuz you're right I
was a little worried about the pivot but
totally played it totally played
perfectly and I know we said somewhere
during the reaction if you're listening
to this on like Spotify or apple we just
watched Loki uh season 2 episode one and
we are reviewing it right now and I was
so impressed with the way it was shot
you know uh Justin and Aaron who did
moonnight which who I thought they did
great work in there and it seems like
they they just kind of got their feet
wet with that and they were able to come
over here and one thing that I feel like
with Marvel the last thing I actually
expected to talk about was specifically
the way this is directed uh and like the
film making behind it was the last thing
I expect weird all of the production
design cinematography dir editing the
music um it and and it it it does feel
like there's a distinct voice that is
one of the biggest criticism that I feel
like we often say with Marvel is you
don't feel like like when I was
revisiting season one of
Loki I was hit with the this nostalgic
feeling of man I forgot how
how composed this was I I forgot just
how it felt like Kate's voice was behind
this so hearing that they were switching
directors made me go okay did they just
get a Hired Hand so they could just kind
of do the show they wanted to that's not
the impression I'm getting like what
what Justin er have done there's they've
I kind of liken it to when um Doug Lyman
did born identity and then they got Paul
Greengrass for Bor Supremacy where okay
now we're handheld we're a little bit
grittier and it really alien to
how the action like accelerated but it
still felt like in a world definitely
but it's it kind of adapts a little bit
of Ridley Scott's uh dread uh here
because it does have this 70s sci-fi
horror touch uh Lac throughout without
losing its sense of of Wonder uh I was
enamored with this uh I I thought this
was I thought this was brilliant like
just talking about like the film making
right at hand uh John what did you think
of film making no yeah I'm absolutely
kind of
I'm so happy right now because I'm a
little blown away because of everything
you just pointed out and Yeah like this
feels like it's crafted like it's
distinct and like this is really able I
I don't know I I'm almost at a loss for
words to how to describe it but yeah
it's like they really the first season
you know felt tangible and it and it had
all these earmarks of quality film
making but this you know use of these
long zooms and these you know kind of
frantic but very you know composed uh
you know like tracking shots and clearly
you're like walking around with this
steady cam like there's just so much
legitimacy that that lends to the sets
to the stakes to the circumstances and
like throughout this I I I made a remark
about movie Magic and I feel like you
know a lot of Marvel movies don't give
me that or Marvel things are fun they're
dazzling but they're not always giving
me that sense of like wow I am beholding
the possibilities of movie Magic and
this had that because it was like it it
legitimizes all the sets and stuff like
that then where there is CGI like you
know it Blends really nicely but clearly
they're really throwing down on all
these designs and things it has humor
without feeling jokey it's for boing
it's thrilling and exciting uh and you
care about each beat of the characters
Journeys as well and uh yeah I don't
know this was just so rich to me this
this gave me kind of everything I was
hoping for and so much more and it also
feels like we just immediately picked up
from the end of SE season 1 and going
like and it even it's F funny that they
had that back and forth with uh uh Ki
kuan's character about like how long has
it been you know because sitting down to
this I was like God it feels like Loki
was a century ago and then during the
episode I was like I feel like I just
watched it yesterday yeah you know or or
like we were just doing the the
experience of of you know seeing it the
first time just yesterday or something
like that um so I mean I could go on
forever but yeah I thought this was
terrific amazing koi
what did you think about Obie I love the
obviously they cast perfectly but I love
especially in that scene how the time
editing and time displacement and the
sets were like full power because they
framed him in the center of a circle and
then not only did the circle slightly
get Fuller for the future and a little
bit emptier for the past but it wasn't
obvious and the fact that they had like
match edited the circle behind Loki so
it was super disorienting and you felt
like stuck out of time they made you
feel like you were out of time while
Loki was discovering what to do with his
being out of time like that was was
genius uh I I Justin and Aaron are are
buddies of mine and I love their work so
dearly and I will totally admit there
was a part of me that was so afraid that
the world would be robbed of some of
their more insane cinematic skill by
them going to a major Studio like I I
legitimately obviously love Marvel but
there's a lot of directors that can make
Marvel stuff and they can like blend
their Style with the Marvel style and
that's great I'm happy for them but I
was so worried that we wouldn't get more
things like spring which is one of my
favorite horror movies ever that they
did years ago and I was so like oh this
is years of their lives and then I liked
a lot of moonight but I didn't love the
ending this was what I was hoping would
happen when you hire directors like
Justin and Aaron like where they let
them paint with their paintbrushes where
you let them have here's a blank check
because we can afford it but also make
the thing you'd make but in our universe
that's what Comics are to me you give a
writer you trust and an artist you trust
the character and you just say like Okay
We're not gonna make coloring in the
lines too detailed but just don't do
these things but everything else just go
nuts yeah and that way you can keep it
in your universe but it's also their
book that's why I like Tom Kings Batman
because it feels like his and that's why
I like what Mitch Gerards does with his
characters because they feel like hiss
and this feels like Justin and Aaron
were like okay we just can't kill Loki
in the first episode because anything
else is fine and it's it's their style
it's their world it's that 70s horror
it's the music that feels original it's
the production design that feels like
not just this feels like you can walk
through this set it doesn't feel like
the void or the volume whatever they
call it it doesn't feel like the volume
this is that's what it feels like to me
but I I love when when things are
tangible and real and I love that two
people that I really respect got to make
something to scale that still feels like
something they'd make not in this
universe yeah yeah know it feels like
it's it has this combination where it
feels storyboarded yet off the cuff at
times like oh let's just watch the
actors work now let's shoot around them
uh there was such energy and vibrancy
and like it's it's literally about the
the the mood of it is a Race Against
Time the structure of they keep adding
ticking clocks yeah you could feel its
rency for the the last season uh all
over it but yet completely doing uh its
own thing here uh everyone's like the
the performances of obviously Tom Heston
great again I want Wilson's thumbs up
was the funniest thing to me like I
couldn't hang I I can't wait for him to
get his jet ski so um yeah the like just
getting their chemistry back feeling
like man we they haven't missed a step
not one bit not one bit here have they
missed the step I I am hoping though
that in some ways they do retain some of
the bit of what we love about Loki
instead of him just being like a a TVA
agent this time who's on edge you want a
bit of that god of Mischief in some
capacity oh I think that's even though
he's been even though he's had a
complete character Arc you I wanted to
still have a bit of what we know about
Loki you know you want a little bit of
his
duplicitousness of course no I I think
that's coming I think what I'm really
intrigued by is uh the rapael casselle
footage we saw in the trailer had his
him as like an actor like a theater
actor and I didn't realize he was going
to be a TVA agent and then we've also
seen some stuff where there's like yeah
so I'm curious what like Loki has to do
to manipulate Rafa's character or like
how he's going to get around the TVA
that are clearly going out and hunting
Sylvie that's where I think we're going
to get some Mischief in there yeah you
know last season we didn't really like
we're going to the political bureaucracy
a lot more here this time around and
before it was just kind of ravona saying
yeah now there's a board now
there's like a board like okay there's
like a lot more people here than just
rone it seemed like it was that it would
seem like she was answering to
timekeepers timekeepers and then there
was ravona yeah right and it and last
season um so we didn't really see much
of like the political debates where
clearly there's a lot more cover
upla branch
she was judicial like there's other
branches going on I mean it like Kang
has create or he who remains has created
such a dichotomy for everyone such a
problem that there is that does come
into question it was what it literally
was what Loki and Sylvie were arguing
about is is is telling the truth better
than than the the lie that Comforts
everyone yeah can I say before all of
the internet does because we we uh we
will hear this at nauseum uh this isn't
Marvel's back but it is to me hey they
can still do that magic and they just
need to like narrow it down if we could
prune some of the phase four stuff that
didn't work in the ho timeline like Kang
Dynasty I think that's what Kang Dynasty
is going to do I think Kang Dynasty is
going to show that we are on disperate
timelines not everything is Canon and
then Marvel can just keep the stuff they
want and I think this show is like they
still got it yeah definitely and and I
think with Kang uh what like this was
the it's so weird because revisiting
season 1 wow what a perfect setup for
king and the Multiverse consequences
should have touched it until this and
and then and then uh you know we saw
what happened and and it felt like a lot
of loky SE season one ending was not
really consequential to the films and
shows that came following it that big
moment everybody's like that's the
moment Everything Changes I'm like so
when do we find out what change this
feels like everything's here two years
later yeah it picks and it's like all
right W I'm I'm in it and and Kang is
back to feeling it makes you forget
about his Ant-Man appearance like
Jonathan
you did did a fine job as Kang in that
film uh but but he was in a different
movie he was a different movie and
overall he got killed by ants well right
so and then here like ah this is the
threatening guy that we were all worried
about and and just uh of how they were
clues about him Lac throughout and you
one thing I hope this show does is kind
of give you a sense of the TVA Society a
bit more seem like we got a hint of that
in the opening action scene um
especially when you got all these
different characters here but then when
Kang it's I imagine that he's going to
be connected to that rona's true past is
probably connected to Victor timley
right because that was what they
established in the end we're going to
see Victor timley as established in
Ant-Man Quantum Mania we're gonna see
Victor timley and I imagine that's where
rona's part of her history truly lies
there as well because I think oops Sor
because yeah she left it last season she
said she was going to go look for him
essentially implying that she was going
to go look for him and it seemed like
the message that Loki was playing was
the thing that was left for him and I
think some of those TVA are going to
there I think they're
going and I think that's where we're
going to see Rafa as the actor right
okay yeah that makes a little that's my
theory is that he's going and hunting
her so it's not just Sylvia they're
going after it's also ravona in the
original timeline because if they cut
off her then we don't find out all this
about Kang and it goes back to status
quo so why are they going after Sylvie
though John what are your theories they
you don't think they are I didn't they
partly establish that or at least that's
what that's Loki assumes Loki assumes
but they but the the the the old the
Irish people and the guy who like she's
Scottish they Scottish whatever they
said they said we have to go after Sil
we have to get Sil they said it in the
boardroom and B15 would say that but
then B15 said this is scen success I
think it's not Jess Sylvie or it's a
mislead but what did they need to go
after Sylvie but maybe they know more
than the rest do at least the the woman
from Game of Thrones seem to know more
the woman from The Witcher seemed more
earnestly uh surprised surprised by this
Revelation whereas the women from Game
of Thrones seemed to be like more aware
more in control and trying to just not
let that on so much so I wonder if maybe
she has got some kind of awareness of he
who remains or the truth of the matter
and is trying to maintain and protect
the lie that everybody lives under or
something I guess would be because you
know if s if she knows Sylvie killed him
then that would be you know the the
reason to prioritize her but there's
also just like this the leftover
circumstances from last time too with
them being on this Manhunt anyway um I
wish the trailers didn't reveal that she
works at McDonald I know I
know I would have love to have almost no
Sylvie in the trailers and then to have
this little post credit bit would have
been really
nice I I personally only watched the one
trailer so I don't really know anything
about I only have those two things in my
head the the actor scene and the Sylvia
McDonald's scene yeah um well I wonder
too if the if the the Rangers and stuff
are going to start encountering varians
of themselves who get to live you know
or something you know as they're going
around I can't get over they all going
in such numbers like I don't know maybe
that's a possibility too man this is
brilliant I I can't get over the visuals
of the cosmic time Distortion the time
waves and stuff that's going to like
stick with me that's that's what the
comics feel like and that was so cool to
see something that feels like a comic
I've read but like in a in a more tense
3D way yeah yeah that was beautiful this
is I mean this is up there with my
favorite uh first episode of anything
this is special this is one of the best
episodes of the Loki show confident
confidently say that yeah this is one of
the absolute best episodes of the Loki
show I'm so glad Justin Aaron on all of
it like I'm so glad it's their show not
like you know switch around directors
I'm sure every people do great but this
like this gives me so much hope for the
whole season yeah but and what I just
really appreciate too is the they are
providing a uniqueness here that feels
that feels different and distinct from
season one and and it and it still they
still understand like turmoil
psychological turmoil like where
moonight was obviously very character
focused uh which which made more sense
for that and here you still get the
emotionality of what everyone's
experiencing so there's still going to
be character- based stuff but it's more
of about IMM mediacy of what they're
experiencing and the tension that
they're going through so I I really
really I was really impressed with this
I I was surprised by how it's like I had
a feeling it would be good but I didn't
think it' be that good I know right I
actively didn't want it to end and I was
Gob smash like I don't I don't often get
like I don't have words and then I also
don't want things to not end Forever
This Is Well it feels vintage in
throwback but also new you know like it
feels vintage it feels now and it feels
future all at the same time time time
well and and part of me I'm I'm curious
too about what they're going to do about
that past beat that we saw with the you
know Kang statue uh because it's clear
Mobius has had his mind wiped number of
times so I'm like is there a recent
previous iteration of the TVA that was
like Lord Kang Central or something yeah
I think that's what it seem to clearly
establish yeah at some point they didn't
have to hide it and like why did he
start hiding it and and and MOB is g to
find out like some kind of horrible
complicitness that he's had to you know
be a part of in the past that he's not
aware of now I also there's a a strange
parallel too to bring it back to Obie
Obie and he who remains you know like
they're both there with these really
important jobs about time displacement
and
whatnot they're isolated and wait for
visitors to come see yeah he hasn't seen
anyone in hundreds of years and he seems
fine too yeah I just I want more like
he's he's almost like a a supplement for
Miss minutes possibly I don't know uh
it's something there's something really
interesting about a mirroring effect
with that see that's the magic is I'm
like I have so many you can draw
theories out of this there are so many
Curiosities and they're all in different
directions there's the circumstances of
story but there's the
character qualities in that and and it's
been a long time for me since I've like
coming into Loki season 2 is like you
know I'm happy to be here I loved the
first season so like this is a pretty
easy bar to clear like it can be you
know if it's just okay I would be honest
about that but I would be still pretty
pleased to be here and so it's been a
long time since I've had that Vibe
coming in and then been so bold over
like wow this went far above and beyond
any expectation I would have had I'm
happy enough to be back but also I'm
overjoyed
that they like really pulled all the
stops out the Guardians for me I knew
I'd love it and then I was like who do I
think is this my favorite of the three
if you look at what's been beloved like
our feelings for this I me I I have a
feeling people are going to love this
yeah sure um this Guardians director's
Vision yes and mostly isolated like
mostly to itself not trying to start 500
spin-offs yeah but you also know it's
connected at the same time without it
like really reaching for that connection
like Loki season 1 and ju Division I
think are the two most separate of the
shows and they did and here we are yeah
this is this is something really this
felt very special to me and this it's
when you get like this of when you
get something mediocre of why mediocre
thing in Marvel stings even more right
capable because you know what yeah you
know what the potential is and phase
four people dog on phase four but let's
not forget it started off with W
division in Loki yeah W division Loki no
way home Shi came out of that it's just
other stuff did to and
and then it's connective tissue and the
lack of consequent like this feels like
oh the repercussions the consequences of
their actions of the Loki's actions from
the end of season one and I think the
benefit of this and Kang and everything
else is time travel does mean you can
clean that up like I do think Secret
Wars and Kang Dy mean like okay guys we
hit Le listen we read the message boards
we're so sorry sweep sweep and like this
is totally a thing yet I feel like the
marketing for this and maybe it has
something to do with Jonathan Major's
you know personal life troubles uh it's
been pretty Qui I feel like the
marketing for this has not been ramped
up as it normally would be for Marvel
I'm hoping but the word of mouth has got
like I know the trailer did phenomenally
well but yet I still feel like the
marketing feels a little quieter than
usual sure yeah I agree I mean I'm
really curious how it ramps up and what
word amount is once it's out because I
do think this is exceptional and I think
that quality is going to make people
that's why I said the first thing like
Marvel's back like I do think it's going
to be that kind of Rush and especially
post Guardians now they're two for two
and so I hope this leads to and the next
thing after this is going to be they're
doing a whole day I think for um last we
heard heard they're doing everything at
once with Echo and then the Captain
America 5 is the first thing under
iger's uh new St four yeah I skipped a
whole Captain America Captain America
four is the first thing under Marvel's
whole scra four entirely yeah we skipped
four we're on to Sam Wilson's five uh
but yeah I think that you know Bob
iger's New Vision and like Kevin feige
having time to readjust to everything
that had to be changed with the pandemic
and everything else like remember Falcon
Winter Soldier had to be like half
reshot like things had to really change
with phase four so I do have some faith
in where we go from here okay so I'm I'm
very
hopeful guys what did you think about it
uh I loved it absolutely loved it a plus
for me that is damn good Television
right there the best Marvel movie since
the Dark Knight is what Twitter will say
easily truth leave your thoughts down
below thank you to all who have been uh
getting some RR apparel means the world
and we will catch you all very very soon
stay tuned for next week and whatever
else gets uploaded on this channel see
you
[Music]
guys